raising backyard chickens in urban areas
is a growing trend study of 150 the most
populated US cities finds 93 percent of
them allow backyard flocks Las Vegas is
one of the latest cities to say yes but
you can find some of the most pampered
chickens in the Bay Area
they belong to tech workers who spend
most of their day in the virtual world
and are looking for a way to reconnect
with nature John Blackstone shows us who
rules the roost in Silicon Valley they
want to interact with you they're fun
they're funny to watch yes so I think it
is a stress release Scott Van der lips
chickens make themselves right at home
come in the house the software engineer
believes he's found the perfect antidote
to computers and code and has the big
data to prove he's not alone there are
thousands maybe 10,000 chicken coops in
Silicon Valley I mean there are a lot of
coops online companies are hatching
plans for do-it-yourselfers to build
stylish backyard coops but in the
million-dollar backyards of Silicon
Valley the coops and the chickens are
really something to crow about she is a
giant Lou Cochin one of my favorite
breeds about this this coop especially
for them this is not your average
chicken coop no no it's not it's right
off of my kitchen and I wanted something
beautiful
Laura Menards custom-built chicken coops
have antique stained glass windows and
detailing added by a master carpenter do
you think your chickens are happier in
there than they might be in coop no I
don't think they care Menard breeds
heritage chickens like the opal leg bar
that can sell for 50 to $100 far above
the $15 price tag on a more common bird
for the valleys growing community of
backyard farmers the investment in
heritage birds pays off in a status
symbol of sorts colorful eggs that can
be given as gifts to friends technology
may pay the bills but doesn't feature
some chickens
that's one way to feature soul
technology pays no han lands bills he's
a top engineer at a leading Silicon
Valley tech company and it's very
stressful at work like a very intensive
situations he balances that intensity by
tending his chickens make sure they have
all the feed that they actually are
laying that's the right temperature flow
so air through the coop for many in
Silicon Valley chickens are no longer
just farm animals they are pampered pets
when Amina is our gram comes home from
work her flock greets her at the back
door and they're always happy to see us
really they want food but you know that
you can interpret it yes the bird
sometimes get a break from eating bugs
with treats like melons and salmon
caring for the chickens is a family
affair Justin and I'd like we will come
home in the evening after a stressful
day at work and pull up our chairs and
just like sit here and watch the
chickens go crazy
of course Silicon Valley is not alone in
discovering the charms of chickens as
well as the challenges how much does it
cost per egg well we don't ask that
question you're probably not saving a
lot of money by having backyard chickens
around the country animal welfare groups
that rescue unwanted chickens are busy
taking in birds that turned out to be
more trouble than their eggs were worth
as much as the backyard farmers of
Silicon Valley lavish love on their
heritage breeds this tech hub is
constantly looking for the next big
thing creating buzz I always tell people
chickens are actually just the gateway
drug to beekeeping beekeeping is the new
thing you know are you suggesting that
some time soon somebody's gonna say to
me I backyard chickens that's so 2018
exactly better not let the chickens here
this has every startup knows get into a
trend too late and you can get stung CBS
this morning John Blackstone Los Altos
Hills California
those chicken coops by the way could go
for $20,000 they've got names like from
williams-sonoma the Range Rover of
chicken coops just in case you're
thinking about yeah chicken coop for the
Soul Matthew Walker with you that sweet
friendly right